[موسيقى]
في هذه البقعه تسري عروق العراق التاريخيه
قال الشاعر الجواهري في يوم من الايام يا
دجله الخير يا ام البساتين لكن المياه تشح
في بلد المياه والبساتين تنازع بسبب
الجفاف
[موسيقى]
السنوات الاربعه الماضيه كانت الاسوء من
حيث تصاعد مؤشرات الجفاف في العراق شحال
الامطار والتغير المناخي سيطر على حال
البلاد المائي واكدت وزاره الموارد
المائيه ان هذا العام هو عمق زجاجه الازمه
والاكثر حرجا منذ ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي
وهذا ما يسبب تهديدا للامن المائي العراقي
كل يوم
[موسيقى]
تتراجع المياه المخزونه في سدود العراق
فمن 60 مليار متر مكعب في عام 2016 يهبط
الرقم بشكل مخيف الى سبعه مليارات
وخمسمائه مليون متر مكعب وهذا الرقم ضئيل
جدا مقارنه بحاجه العراق من المياه
[موسيقى]
الازمه ليست مائيه فحسب فما يحدث من شوح
المياه تنعكس اثاره على قوه العراقيين
اليومي وبالتالي تخرج الاف الهكتارات
الزراعيه عن الخطه الانتاجيه ويصبح العراق
تحت تهديد نقص حاد بالخيرات الزراعيه التي
كانت يوما ما عنوانا لبلاد وادي الرافدين
زينب المشاط صباح العربيه البصره